um
well i guess i should start by saying i
never really really liked
maths but um at the start of year 11 um
i looked down at my timetable and i saw
three uh very reassuring letters
and they were w o and o
and um say it's actually in this blue's
class i know the
year i learned an incredible thing about
mr wu
um this is ability to explain the most
complicated ideas
um simply so for example once uh to
explain
the idea of um locusts basically it's a
posh wrapping thing where
you don't give you the equation you get
the description of the graph to explain
the logos he um
got an entire class um into the passive
area and
used the cracks in the paving slabs as
the axis
and brought us all to sand around on in
circles and lines and parabolas which
was
hilarious and um i think
maybe mr was so good at explaining
because um it wasn't long ago that
he's asked exactly where we are today
and for those of you who
don't know listen we went to ruse and he
graduated i think in 2003.
and this is great because um he treats
everyone as an adult but
sometimes this translates into him not
leaving our admittedly dodgy excuses or
not doing our homework
and also giving us a very um
disappointed but
inspiring speech about why would you be
honest
and then put something that's on youtube
um
all in all um mr wu has been an
incredible teacher
he has i think this is incredible and i
think it's
impossible um but for everyone except
for this
we've managed to inspire and interest
everyone
uh in everyone the respect for maths
and even those who really didn't like
the subject to begin with
but by the end of last year we knew that
things had changed because um
for the first time uh none of the new
year 11's
on this four campuses took mr luke for
students
this was
mr wu ever since you announced your
leaving it's been a bucket of mixed
emotions for all of us
on one hand we are unbelievably excited
for you
we know that you'll enjoy your new
position and it's needless to say how
nice and proud we are of you
but on the other hand it's been very
different
without you in class and on the field
on the touch field for those who don't
know mr bury has
the endurance like no math teacher
we've missed how you've always been here
to support us teach us new things
and encourage us to be the best we can
be
you've always taught us to shoot the
stars
and you believed in us even and
especially when we didn't believe in
ourselves
you've inspired us and let us by example
and although we will continue to miss
you
we wish you the very best of luck at
terry brook tech
i trust they already love you as much
i'm sure
i can put this in my other one
which
rosie also has a present from mustache
girls
you